pledges of unwavering support for
Ukraine came from NATO's Secretary
General Yen stoltenberg along with a
warning that Russia is weaponizing
Winter by attacking energy
infrastructure he says NATO has found
new ways to help Ukraine President Putin
is trying to force ukrainians to freeze
or flee
and today alas made additional pledges
non-lethal support including Fuel and
generators helping Ukraine to address
the consequences of Russia's strikes
against their power grid and the U.S has
announced it will supply equipment worth
53 million dollars to help repair
Ukraine's electricity grid earlier
stoltenberg had assured Romania that its
Air Force and troops were being backed
up by extra reinforcements Romania has
usf-16 aircraft that are replacing
outdated former Soviet migs and their
pilots are fully stretched everything is
under pressure so we were time limited
all the time we fight against the second
Romania coordinates with other NATO
forces in policing its airspace defense
to the skies above NATO's Eastern flank
has never been so intense NATO faces a
colossal challenge not just in the air
but on the ground too
Russia would call this escalation NATO
prefers the word deterrence here U.S and
Romanian forces on an exercise recently
there were tests of air and missile
defenses but Ukraine is saying such
Weaponry is desperately needed its side
of the border and the supply line of
weapons that are available is too slow
decisions
on weapons decision on launching new
production lines of weapons in Western
countries they have to be made faster
the quandary NATO faces is that it won't
take a direct hand in the deployment of
weaponry and so it's down to individual
states but some only want to give
non-lethal support
ukrainians May well observe that if
energy infrastructure is repaired it
won't last for long unless Ukraine's air
defenses aren't drastically improved
sooner rather than later
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera Bucharest